we're told to factor four x to the
fourth y minus eight x third y
minus two x squared so to factor this we
need to figure out what the greatest
common factor of each of these terms are
so let me rewrite it so we have 4
x to the fourth y
and we have minus 8
x to the third y
and then we have
minus 2 x squared so in the other videos
we looked at it in terms of breaking it
down to its simplest parts but i think
we have enough
practice now to be able to do a little
bit more of it in our head so what is
the largest number that divides into all
of these when i say number i'm actually
talking about the actual i guess
coefficients we have a 4 an 8 a 2 we
don't have to worry about the negative
signs just yet and we say well the
largest of the largest common factor of
2 8 and 4 is 2. that's 2 goes into all
of them and obviously that's the largest
number that can go into 2. so that is
the largest number that that's that's
going to be part of the greatest common
factor so let's write that down so it's
going to be 2
and then what's the greatest i guess
factor what's the greatest degree of x
that's divisible into all three of these
well
x squared goes into all three of these
and obviously that's the greatest degree
of x that can be divided into this last
term so x squared is going to be the
great is going to be the greatest the
greatest common x degree in all of them
2x squared and then what's the largest
degree of y that's divisible into all of
them
well these two guys are divisible by y
but this guy isn't so there is no degree
of y that's divisible into all of them
so the lar the greatest common factor of
all three of these guys right here is 2x
squared so what we can do now is we can
think about each of these terms as the
product of 2x squared and something else
and to figure out something else we can
literally undistribute the 2x squared
and say this is the same thing or even
before we undistribute the 2x squared we
could say look 4x to the fourth y's the
same thing as 2x squared
times
x to the 4th y
over 2x squared
right if you just multiply this out
you'd get 4xy similarly you could say
that
you could say that 8x to the third y
i'll put the negative out front
you could say that 8x to the 3rd y is
the same thing as 2x squared our
greatest common factor
times 8x to the third
y over 2x squared and then finally 2x
squared is the same thing as if we
factor out 2x squared so we have that
negative sign out front we have this
negative sign 2
x squared if we factor out 2x squared
same thing as 2x squared times 2x
squared over 2x squared this is almost
silly what i'm doing here but i'm just
showing you that i'm i'm just
multiplying and dividing both of these
terms by 2x squared multiplying and
dividing multiplying and dividing here
it's trivially simple this just
simplifies to
2x squared right there or this 2x
squared times 1.
that simplifies to 1. maybe i should
write it below
that simplifies to 1. but what do these
simplify to
so this first term over here this
simplifies to 2
x squared times now you get 4 divided by
2 is 2
x to the fourth divided by x squared
is x squared and then y divided by
1 is just going to be a y
so it's 2x squared times 2x squared y
and then you have minus
2x
squared times 8 divided by 2 is 4
x to the third divided by x squared is x
and y divided by 1 you can imagine is
just y
and then finally of course you have
minus 2x squared minus 2x squared times
this right here simplifies to 1 times 1.
now if you were to undistribute 2x
squared if you were if you were to
undistribute 2x squared out of the
expression out of the expression
you'd essentially get 2x squared
times
this term minus this term minus this
term right if you distribute this out if
you take that out of each of the terms
you get 2x squared times this 2
x squared y
minus
minus 4xy
and then you have minus 1
minus one and we're done we're factored
the problem now it looks like we did a
lot of steps and the reason why i kind
of went through great pains to show you
exactly what we're doing is so you know
exactly what we're doing in the future
you might be able to do this a little
bit quicker you might be able to do many
of the steps in your head you might say
okay let me look at each of these well
the biggest
coefficient that fit that divides all of
these is a 2 so let me put that 2 let me
factor 2 out well all of these are
divisible by x squared that's the
largest degree of x let me factor an x
squared out
and this guy doesn't have a y so i can't
factor a y out so see it's going to be
2x squared times and what's this guy
divided by 2x squared well 4 divided by
2 is 2 x to the 4th divided by x squared
is x squared y divided by 1 there is no
other y degree that we factored out so
it's just going to be y and then you
have minus
8 divided by 2 is 4
x to the third divided by x squared is x
and then you have y divided by say one
is just y and then you have minus
two divided by two is one
x squared divided by x squared is one so
two x squared divided by two squared is
just a one so in the future you'll do it
more like this where you kind of just
factor it out in your head but i really
want you to understand what we did here
there is no magic and to realize that
there's no magic you could just use the
distributive property to multiply this
out again
to multiply it out again you're going to
see that you get exactly
this